what's going on guys in this video i'm
gonna explain the different draw titans
in attack on titan
ranging from the present day of the
series all the way back to the ancient
titans that existed before the series
began
for the draw titans that we properly
know i'll be explaining their backstory
as well as what makes that titan unique
and for most of the other drawers that
only have a brief appearance i'll
examine what we know about them
if anything and i'll also give their
design a rating out of 10 if i find it
interesting
it goes without saying that every jaw
titan has at least a few things in
common regardless of how different their
designs may be
for example they each have an amazing
crushing strength which was best
displayed when porko was forced to
destroy the warhammer titan's crystal
additionally they all have claws that
can slice through pretty much anything
and their small size allows them to be
more acrobatic and sneaky when compared
to the other titans
before we get into it don't forget to
sub to the channel for more attack on
time videos like this
and if you're an anime only viewer then
later in this video there will be
spoilers but i'll give a big warning
before we get to that
okay so the first draw tyson on this
list is marcel galliard who was one of
the four warriors chosen to infiltrate
parody's island
despite not having much screen time we
still know a lot about martial's
personality due to the comments made by
other people
for starters we know that he was a
confident and reliable leader of the
group
as annie believed the mission wouldn't
be successful without him and reiner
subsequently tried to imitate martial's
leadership whilst on the island
marcel was perhaps the physically
strongest of his age group as he came
first place in his endurance race
with porco also singling out marcel for
his strength we saw in the anime how
marcel was protective over his younger
brother
even going as far as to influence mali
to give reiner the armored titan instead
of porco
he presumably did this to you know let
his little brother have a long life
which is similar to falco's desire to
protect gabby from inheriting the titan
as well
marcel's draw titan had a good design
with bulletproof hardened skin covering
his entire face
a prominent set of teeth hardened claws
and a goatee that 12 year old marcel
never had in normal circumstances
we saw this titan in a flashback during
marley's invasion of another country
but sadly he was eaten not too long
after that
moving on ymir was the first draw titan
that we actually saw in this series
and she undeniably had one of the worst
lives of any character
in the beginning she was a nameless
orphan living on the streets of mali
before she was picked up by this cult
leader who gave her a name
he decided to call her ymir because ymir
fritz was the name of the original
founding titan who is a respected
historical figure in the eyes of many
alden restorationists
the man was able to grow his cult by
pretending that ymir had royal blood
and people in this cult began to worship
her almost like a god
this was probably the most carefree
period of ymir's life as she was well
fed and was making other people happy
just by existing
i'd say the happiest person though was
the cult leader as he was amassing a ton
of wealth based off this scam
things eventually fell apart when the
cult was busted by malian authorities
with all members being sent to parody's
island when the court was discovered
she tried to play the role of ymir in
the hope that it would save everyone's
life
but it was no effect as they were all
turned into pure titans
for 60 years yamir would wander parodies
island as a mindless monster
until one morning she happened to
encounter the warriors of mali
she initially tried to eat rainer but
marcel pushed him out of the way and was
eaten by ymir instead
by consuming the spine of a titan
shifter ymir regained her humanity and
became the new draw titan in the process
unlike her predecessor ymir had no
hardened skin covering her
face and her claws were of a
significantly smaller size
her body proportions were also quite
strange and the teeth specifically
they were not even close to the size of
marcel that said
yumi's titan still displayed some great
agility throughout the series
swinging from titan to titan in its
first appearance and then later swinging
from tree to tree like some kind of
monkey
yamir's draw titan is also capable of
speech which is you know that's not a
trait that we've seen from other draw
titans in the series
so she was definitely special in her own
way the third draw titan on this list is
porco galliard who as we already
established is the younger brother of
marcel
pogo inherited this titan after yamir
willingly let herself be taken back to
mali
and when we were first introduced to the
character he gets straight into the
action by protecting gabby and falco
from enemy fire
on the battlefield he's shown to often
be a useful asset for mali
such as when he saved reiner from being
killed or when he snuck up on aaron from
behind and nearly stole the founding
titan
on the other hand he can also be a
hothead and blinded by rage
which results in him making short-term
rash decisions that negatively affect
the people around him
porko's draw titan is very similar to
his brothers in terms of its design
however they are not completely
identical unlike marcel
pogo's draw titan technically has two
sets of teeth the first is the sharp set
on the inside of his mouth
and the second is the hardened skin on
the outside that fits together like
puzzle pieces
this differs from marcel as we can see
that he has no jagged teeth on the
inside of his mouth
but his exterior teeth are significantly
sharper than what porcos are
with that said the rest of this video
will contain really heavy spoilers
regarding the draw titan
so as of posting this video if you're an
anime only watcher then you definitely
need to pause right now
once the final season of attack on titan
is over then i encourage you to come
back to this video and finish it
but until then don't continue watching
now the next draw titan on this list is
probably the most interesting
as it's essentially a hybrid between the
draw titan and the beast titan
i'm of course referring to the flying
jaw titan that first appeared in chapter
129
but before we get into the titan itself
let's talk about its user
falco was introduced as a warrior
candidate from mali and is a member of
the grey's family his uncle was one of
the leading members of the alien
restorationists
alongside aaron's father and his older
brother colt was the designated
successor to inherit the beast titan
in the beginning we saw how falco's love
for gabby motivated him
to try and inherit the armored titan
because he believed that if he got it
then gabby would live a long life
his feelings for her caused him to make
major decisions in the series so far
including when he followed her to
parody's island and jumping to protect
her when nicolo attempted to whack her
with a wine bottle
the decision to protect gabby in that
moment is what inadvertently led to
falco inheriting his flying titan
as the wine bottle he was struck with
contained zeke's spinal fluid
without zeke's spinal fluid entering his
mouth falco never would have become what
he became
so let's get into what makes his titan
so special
to start with falco's draw titan
possesses two sets of teeth
with the inner mouth looking like a
regular titan and the outer drawer being
a hardened set of jagged teeth
when he closes this outer drawer you'll
notice that he literally looks like he
has a beak
which is because the spinal fluid gave
falco's titan more animalistic features
both his arms are covered in thick fur
which is obviously reminiscent of zeke's
beast titan
and his hands are genuinely just bird
claws these claws were strong enough to
crumble the roof of a building on its
first appearance
and later in the manga we see that
falco's titan has evolved even further
these memories of a previous flying
beast titan are what made falco realize
that he has the potential to do this
himself
when we finally saw him flying he
sprouted a full set of wings with an
enormous wingspan
in chapter 136 falco performs a maneuver
in the air where he speeds up to avoid
incoming arrows
which i thought was an incredible
maneuver because this is his first day
using the flying titan he's already able
to do tricks like this
i guess marley's warrior training
literally prepares you for anything
considering all factors this might just
be the most useful draw titan ever
as he can do everything that a regular
draw titan can do with the extra benefit
of being able to fly through the air
if falco has a successor in the future
do you guys think that they will also
inherit these beast titan
characteristics
or is it like falco had the spinal fluid
so it's only reserved for him
but the next person will not have the
beast titan is
kind of confusing how this works but let
me know your thoughts on it in the
comments down below
moving on what we're going to do now is
look at some of the ancient draw titans
throughout history
and i'll be giving some of them a rating
out of 10 for the design because why not
back in chapter 122 we saw what was
possibly the first draw titan to ever
exist
and i say that because when you look at
the whole context of the chapter
it would make total sense for this to be
the first one its most notable aspect
was the fact that its head was just a
skull
which is a feature it seemingly
inherited from the original founding
titan
this draw titan made another appearance
in chapter 137
and i imagine his hollow eyes will make
it pretty frightening when this
eventually gets animated
based on its design i'm going to give
this draw titan a solid 7 out of 10.
the next titan is another one of these
ancient shifters and it has hardened
skin covering its face
similar to poco and marcel it has a set
of normally shaped teeth inside its
mouth
and even though its hands don't have
sharp claws it was still able to slice
through the body of the cart titan in
one swoop
around the eye area it has a unique
design with two rectangular sockets
which makes me feel like this was a
helmet that was specially designed by
yamir
whatever the case this design gets a
nearly perfect 9 out of 10 rating from
me
in the same chapter a different draw
titan was revealed that i think looks
kind of similar to falco
this draw titan is what falco's draw
titan would have looked like
if he never had zeke's spinal fluid
obviously i have no evidence to back
that up but i'm just saying
when i look at this thing i'm like yeah
falco definitely would have looked like
this
if he wasn't a beast titan basically let
me know what you guys think about that i
mean
obviously it's just my gut feeling but
i'm going to give this design an 8 out
of 10.
over here we had another interesting
draw titan and i wish we'd seen it more
up close because
this hardened face is pretty unique the
shape is just so weird that i'm kind of
wondering
how exactly does it open and close but i
assume that we
maybe will get to see that when this is
animated also as a random side note
this draw titan right next to it is a
strong contender
for one of the ugliest titan shifters i
have ever seen honestly i kind of feel
bad for mapper having to one day bring
this arc to life
because there's just a million titans
all fighting at once it's going to be so
hard
the final draw titan that i thought was
worth talking about is this
interesting creature and i initially was
conflicted about whether this was
a jaw titan or a cart titan or a beast
titan
but after a discussion with my boy
oceans we agreed that its draw seemed to
be its defining feature
and therefore it is likely a draw titan
i'll give this design a 7 out of 10
because the shape of its draw is unlike
anything we've seen before
and it kind of makes me wonder does it
have better biting power than the other
draw titans
before i go i gotta say my favorite draw
titan is probably falco's
although this guy comes in at a close
second place as always be sure to drop a
like as it does help out the video and
the channel
and hit that sub button if you haven't
already until the next one
peace out